hello you're watching the daily climate
show on sky news coming up on today's
program
paying the world's climate debt research
suggests wealthy countries must double
their commitment to help smaller
economies cope with the cost of global
warming
the government-backed green savings bond
goes on sale today but with better
investments for savers on the market
who's likely to buy it
and we discuss whether companies growing
their green credentials by carbon
offsetting is a viable option in the
long term with climate activist michaela
loach and tom burke chairman of the e3g
think tank
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
who's paying for the cost of climate
change is a topic high on the agenda for
this year's global climate summit
it's because an agreement in 2015 among
wealthy nations to provide developing
countries with 72 billion pounds a year
to help cover the costs hasn't been paid
and now new research has found that the
more industrialized countries should be
committing to double this amount to help
smaller economies cope with events from
flooding and fires to the effects of air
pollution but which countries are the
biggest offenders and who should pay the
bulk of this climate deaths
well based on historical emissions the
center for global development estimates
that oecd countries the world's richest
and most developed nations are
responsible for 44.5
of the debt that's 37
nations in total including the uk and
the us
brazil russia india china and south
africa owe just over a third of the
total climate debt
the research says russia and china in
particular have contributed very
significantly to recent emissions
then finally only 21.3
of the remaining debt should be paid by
other nations
well joining me to talk us through this
research is author of the report and
senior policy fellow at the center for
global development ian mitchell evening
to you ian
how prominent an issue is this going to
be at the upcoming cop 26 summit
so i think climate finance is a very big
issue the uh lower income countries and
developed nations were looking for the
for the industrialized countries the
ones that have created the damage to the
climate to make good on their promise to
provide
100 billion dollars per year in private
finance and i think that issue is second
only to to the emissions reductions that
we need to see from from all countries
but it's certainly a hot topic and the
industrialized countries haven't met
that 100 billion target yet
even though it was due in 2020. so the
greatest impacts are being felt by the
the poorest nations what what kind of
costs are we talking about for the less
developed countries
so
the the cost of look at put a ton of
carbon um as having costs hidden costs
if you like of 50 per ton
so
ultimately that's going to be things
like um the obvious damage that we know
about things like flood damage to
buildings and to communities and
livelihoods um but also more subtle
damage to agricultural yields
um and and to to other processes that
that depend on the climate so so our
work looked at if you looked
historically at those missions and you
put that cost against them um how much
would that add up to and as your police
said
in in broad terms and focused on the
industrialized countries of the oecd
we think it's more like 190 billion yeah
rather than the current target which is
100. so in who needs to to pay up and
and what happens if they don't
so
in the first instance i think um the
countries need to make the commitment
was made in 2009 for 100 billion per
year
um and and some countries have stepped
up so germany for example they are
providing substantially more
overall finance and climate finance
the uk is doing less well it has
increased its climate finance but it's
reduced other parts of its budget um but
really the country that's doing least
but has done most damage to the
environment is the u.s
so we now of course invite an
administration that's taking this issue
much more seriously um but in terms of
those rich country emissions um his us
is really around 40 percent of the total
um and so if you take that
simplistically then you might imagine
that they'd be responsible for uh 40 of
100 billion and 40 billion their pledges
at the moment are coming in around 10 so
so certainly they've got a long way to
go
okay ian mitchell thanks very much
indeed for talking to us at this evening
here on the daily climate show
now the government is plowing hundreds
of millions of pounds into investment in
new green technologies and now consumers
are being encouraged to invest too from
today savers can put their money into a
green bond backed by the treasury but
the return offered is somewhat below
other savings products on the market the
savings rate on a three-year fixed-term
green savings bond offered by ns and i
is 0.65
that compares to 1.81
from jn bank for savers to invest over
the same period of time or 1.77
from qib uk our business presenter ian
king has more
it's very difficult to see who is going
to want to invest in these bonds issued
by national savings and investments
they're paying a rate of some 0.65 per
cent over a three year period that is a
fixed rate product now to put that into
context to show you just how
uncompetitive a rate of interest that is
well the market leading product for a
three year fixed rate bond right now is
paying 1.81
so in other words if you were to invest
in these green bonds rather than go with
the market leading product it would cost
you something like 700 pounds in
foregone interest over the next three
years and to also put it into context
three-year government gilts right now uk
government ious well the yield on that
is some point seven three percent right
now so you'd even be better off buying
uk government bonds than you would
buying these green bonds from national
savings and investments it's very very
hard indeed to see who would want to buy
these bonds other than someone that
wants a warm glow they're certainly not
going to get rich on them
in some of today's other climate news a
new unicef study has found that as many
as 9 out of 10 children are worried
about the impacts of climate change
extreme weather events animals becoming
extinct less food and water and harm to
people's health are among their biggest
concerns
the saddest thing i think from the
report was that 89 of those children
just that spoke to us just feel that not
enough is being done about climate
change
and
as climate anxiety as as you've termed
it there gets worse it's it's
it's only natural that more and more
people engage and speak up about this
subject as it becomes more and more real
to their lives
and climate protests have taken place
across the world as campaigners demand
urgent action to curb global warming
thousands of people rallied at berlin's
iconic brandenburg gate calling on the
next german government to prioritize
climate change protests also took place
in uganda bangladesh and india
with just over a week to go until cop 26
the crucial u.n climate change
conference sky news has been speaking to
one of the longest standing
environmentalists in the world dr jane
goodall my colleague samantha washington
spoke to her about her hopes and
concerns for the summit in glasgow and
how the world can recover from the
dramatic climate change that she's
witnessed throughout her life
i think that environmentally we're going
through pretty dark times
and you know we're facing climate change
lots of biodiversity
we've still struggling with this
pandemic
and all of this we brought upon
ourselves by our absolute disrespect of
nature and of animals
we talk a lot about tipping points don't
we uh are there species are there parts
of the world where you think we've
already gone past that tipping point
i think if we get together now we've
still got these little windows of time
around the world
but i don't know that those windows are
very big and i do know that they're
still in most places closing so i just
have to hope
and pray
that at cop 26 this big gathering of
people
they will follow through on commitments
made
i know that your big message is one of
hope it's what your book is about it's
what your podcast is about
uh we're on the eve metaphorically
aren't we of of cop 26
but as you say hope is not a passive
thing is it what do we need to actually
see happen
well what we need to do i mean i've just
recently thought that
it's like being in a very dark tunnel
we're in a very dark tunnel now and
right at the end of it it's this little
gleam of light that's hope but between
us and that light if there are obstacles
that light isn't going to come to us
we've got to get to it we've got to
climb over crawl under work our way
around these obstacles
because hope isn't you know i don't sit
and look at the world through rose
tinted spectacles i know the problems we
face
but there are so many examples of what
we can do if we put our minds to it and
work together then we can turn things
around so hope is about having a
a goal and taking action to get there
when you look at the state of the planet
um
what do you make of the billions that's
being poured into space exploration
i find it
it's almost i don't know it's almost
insulting
i mean some of that money think what it
could do
in a country like bangladesh you know
climate change is eating away
the actual land of bangladesh and people
who live as free farmers with lovely
lives i've seen pictures of it
now their farms are being washed away by
the river and the ocean
and
they're having to go into slums where
there's no sanitation
no electricity
and no jobs
and some of this huge amount of money on
space research
and uh of course it's all i suppose to
do with the military you know we're
going to have space wars next in reality
i've lived long enough on this planet to
have seen science fiction come true
again and again and again
and some people say that it's more to do
with billionaires egos
well
maybe it is but i'd much rather that the
billionaires
spent their money
down here making a difference
the thoughts of jane goodall then now do
stay with us coming up after the break
i'll be joined by climate activist
michaela loach and tom burke chairman of
the e3g think tank we're going to be
discussing who should pay for the green
transition and if offsetting is an
effective way of reducing the world's
carbon emissions we'll see in a couple
of
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
well there's a real sense now that
people beginning to expect that this
whole airlift is coming to an end and
they're really really desperate
we saw snatch squads going in grabbing
people and putting them into trucks
[Music]
you either live and recover
or
[Music]
we help you understand the world with us
over the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
[Music]
to take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
they were convinced the united states
would become hooked when they were right
we're enormous explosion it's just come
down i think the monsters just landed in
between
us the information on this could bring
down the entire network not just in iraq
and syria but across the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
did you know that driving us to school
creates extra toxic air at drop-off and
pick-up times
[Music]
it will be a chilly start on saturday
with a frost in the northeast fog
patches in the south and a few showers
around western coasts and hills
wet and windy weather spread across
ireland northern ireland and western
scotland through the day the rest of
britain will be mostly fine and it will
be a touch milder the rain will turn
persistent over parts of ireland and
western scotland and could lead to local
flooding
air pollution levels are expected to
remain low on saturday with levels
between 1 and 3 on the daily air quality
index
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news we're getting
straight to discussing the climate
issues of the day with climate activists
michaela loach and tom burke chairman of
the e3g think tank
first up the government has promised to
invest hundreds of millions of pounds in
low carbon technologies as part of its
net zero strategy
but critics have warned it won't cover
the cost of the green transition and
consumers will end up footing the bill
it raises questions about how the costs
should be shared out between the
government taxpayers and businesses so
who should pay for net zero tom to you
first we know that there are big changes
that need to be made in order uh to move
towards net zero this week the focus has
been on on that of of heat pumps across
to consumers as well as government but
whose responsibility ultimately is it to
foot these massive bills
well in some sense it's all of our
responsibility because it's all of us
who are creating the problem but how we
pay is very much a question whether
governments uh how government which
policies they choose uh for distributing
those costs and if governments choose to
ban policies then the cost will fall
unfairly on the people who can least
afford it but if it chooses the right
policies then what we'll be doing is
making sure that um the taxpayer pays
some of it consumers pay some of it
business pays some of it and that's a
question therefore of how the government
chooses to set up policy framework so
that we can all respond in a way that's
appropriate to our own particular
circumstances and of course our own
means so how we pay for it michaela but
also when the timing of when we deal
with these bills do we need to pay for
it now
or can we leave it to future generations
so i think i also kind of want to go
back to the question of like who is
responsible because i think too often
we make this too broad we say that we
are responsible for the climate crisis
of humanity is when in reality when 100
companies are responsible for 71 of
greenhouse gas emissions since 1988
there are particular people very small
group of people and companies and
systems that are responsible for this
problem and therefore i think that it's
important that we kind of zoom out on
that a bit more and stop making about
like all individuals who many of whom
are marginalized and instead make it
about these industries and these
businesses and that's why i think that
these businesses and especially the
fossil fuel industry should be paying
now um currently the uk government gives
huge amounts of subsidies to this
industry so in the north sea since 2016
the uk government has given four billion
pounds of public money in this industry
and hasn't been a lot of these companies
have been paying tax so imagine if
instead these companies are being taxed
well now and they are the ones who
caused the crisis if they were instead
being the ones funding this transition
and i think that they could do that and
they should be doing that now
and tom have we got political consensus
on this on how and when we pay
no we we haven't uh got political
consensus on how there are some people
who think we can delay uh some people
typically think we can somehow put off
uh delaying paying for this and for
government playing the party it needs to
pay uh in playing and that's that's kind
of really very silly at the end of the
day you know
i listened to the chancellor the other
day talk about his reluctance to borrow
more money because it would impose costs
on uh our children well
if he's not prepared to borrow the money
to invest in uh on uh uh doing the
damage we're doing to the climate then
he certainly will be making our children
pay but they won't be paying him money
they'll be paying a very damaged uh
lives so i think it's really important
for government to play his part and
michaela's quite right it's very
important that uh businesses pays and
she was absolutely right point out to
the fact there's something completely
silly by paying fossil fuel companies
subsidies at the same time as you're
trying to get other people to pay in
order to undo the damage being done by
those subsidies
michaela i could see you nodding along
with tom on that
yeah absolutely i think that it is
completely outrageous that this
government that says they have no magic
money tree or that they don't have the
money to fund the climate um the just
transition that we need are then paying
loads of public money to non-sea oil and
gas companies who are multi-billion
pound companies that don't need this
money and that are actually laying off
so many workers in the north sea
currently and are trying to expand into
new oil fields they're just being
promoted and polluting and it's
completely ridiculous and especially
when like my generation and the younger
generation are going to be the ones
putting the bills for the
decommissioning costs of these rigs that
are being built now it just feels
completely ludicrous and i think that
when we're talking about like who should
be paying we need to be making sure that
it's the people who have caused this
crisis okay let's move on now to one way
that companies are dealing with global
warming emissions and that is carbon
offsetting firms plan to reach net zero
through planting trees or restoring
carbon sinks like peatlands this is so
the amount of co2 absorbed can balance
out the amount of co2 they emit but is
carbon offsetting a viable long-term
solution tom what are your thoughts is
it a good tool to help us reduce
emissions
it's a very important tool
to have in our toolkit for dealing with
uh climate change but it's only going to
be a useful tool if people believe it's
real the integrity of the offsets in
other words
if you're putting a an atom of carbon
into the atmosphere today you've got to
be able to point to somewhere where
you're taking an atom out of an atom of
carbon out of the atmosphere today you
can't somehow borrow from the future and
i think quite a lot of the schemes seem
to be drifting into somebody's thinking
we will we will put carbon up now and
we'll take it out later and i think that
will really uh
not sustaining public confidence not
sustaining even economic confidence in
offsetting and that will destroy one of
the tools we'll need to play a part not
a dominant part but certainly a part
michaela what are your thoughts does it
work
or
are
carbon offsets a smoke screen
effectively a way of offsetting guilt
and saying well if we pay we can carry
on doing what we've always done
i think that's absolutely it i think
that i do see that it's a tool in a
toolkit but i don't think it should be
the one that we're focusing on i think
that we know what we need to do is
actually stop producing as many
emissions that should be the priority
not trying to do some sort of creative
accounting to make it look like we're
not causing as much harm because
basically what carbon offsets allow a
lot of big businesses and countries like
the uk to do is continue polluting and
emitting and continue fossil fuel
extraction by saying that you're
balancing it out somewhere else but
actually a lot of these carbon offsets
aren't as reliable as they say they are
if you're doing tree planting if those
trees don't end up growing to full
maturity if they end up like dying in
different ways and that's not actually
going to offset as much carbon as you're
saying it is but also there's an
important um kind of thing to bring in
here around justice because a lot of
these carbon offsetting um activities
they are kind of like modern day
colonialism it's called carbon
colonialism and how they go into many um
countries all over the world and seize
land from indigenous people and grow
monoculture of trees this is happening
in kenwa in um the sangwei community in
kenya at the moment for uk for the uk
government's offsetting um kind of uh
strategy and it's really important that
we bring awareness to the fact that this
offsetting can actually cause a huge
amount of harm and in many ways it can
also um kind of repeat the same cause
the same harm that has caused this
crisis in the first place and i think we
need to make sure we're centering
justice and i don't think that sometimes
offsetting can do that
one very brief thought from you tom is
it a long-term solution
uh
well yeah i suspect we're going to go on
needing carving offset but kain is right
to say there are limits to what the
party can play
we have to scale down an investment in
fossil fuels at the same time as we
scaling up investment in the uh
renewables say the net zero alternatives
and and that's a difficult task we've
got to make you can't just switch off
the fossil fuels or we'd all be having
the kind of
problems michaela's worried about carbon
offsetting casting costing if we
actually use it to destroy people's
possibility of living so we've got to
make a good match between those two
things and offsetting will play a role
tom and michaela we are running out of
time i'm gonna have to interrupt you
thank you very much indeed do stay tuned
though coming up next we'll be talking
about alec baldwin who said his heart is
broken
you